welcome to
fat man beyond it's me kevin smith i
am mark bernardin hi hey
oh that's our muppet
up at intro going on how's everybody
doing man
we were supposed to do this 24 hours ago
better snake than lever
as they say um we're doing it tonight on
a sunday however
heads up because we uh we had
emma caulfield was gonna be on uh
yesterday
but then i guess this morning she woke
up not feeling that well so she's not
gonna be on
tonight so it's just me and mark kids
it's old school
yeah you're gonna have to settle for for
us thankfully i'm
like pretty baked so i think we're in
for a
a good show and a [ __ ] love fest for
episode four of one division that i'm
sure not even mr mark bernardin
can find fault with we'll see
um thanks for hanging out with us uh we
got a sponsor tonight ladies and
gentlemen bear with us because
we want to bear with them because uh
they make this all possible and speaking
of bear
they're gonna make your balls bear
ladies and gentlemen that's right we're
talking about
manscaped valentine's day coming man
that means it's time to get them balls
right and good
uh if you go to manscaped.com right now
as we're talking about this
um you're gonna get 20 off and free
shipping with the word
fat man 20 all one word
your balls will thank you um 20
off and free shipping you can't [ __ ]
fight that deal particularly
with valentine's day coming it's time to
shave your balls
that's what she wants for valentine's
day she don't even want your balls
or he nobody wants balls they're
terrible but
at least get them all right and plum
get their hair off them and [ __ ] like
that how do you do that good folks at
manscape is that correct mark
absolutely the people they want they
want quails eggs that's what they're
looking for they're not looking for
[ __ ] coconuts they're not looking for
kiwis they're looking for
smooth perfection and how better to do
that [ __ ] manscape
you can come out of the quarantine with
clean balls thanks to the lawnmower 3.0
it's waterproof skin safe trimmer will
reduce nicks to your two best friends
third generation trimmer even has a
light to shine a path to the promised
land
can you imagine there's a there's a
light on this shaver
so you know oh you can't miss where
you're going and stuff like that plus
you can just use it
in the dark as well there will be no
atheists in foxholes
no nicks and scrapes and bungles let me
tell you
come out of the corn team with clean
balls you fools
thanks to the lawnmower 3.0 man the
third generation
trimmer as mark says has the light they
got the crop preserve preserver
which is an anti-chafing ball deodorant
moisturizer not nuts man you use
you know roll-on or d.o on your armpits
what about ball deodorant man for the
smelliest of all the
things you know it's way down there
right near the ass and stuff when your
neighbor is an [ __ ] chances are it's
gonna rub off on
on you uh you know that's don't take
that as an analogy and
and please don't take that as a any sort
of uh
slogan that the good folks at manscape
provide
this is all that's noisy i'm just
winging it right now man
um you wanna you you wanna keep it fresh
down there
so you can use the crop preserver man
and they also got crop reviver which is
ball toner spray that's if you're on the
go
see the deodorant it's like you stretch
them out you
put it up and down and stuff the toner
mark
is if you're like i ain't got time to
[ __ ] go through a ball routine
but you do have time for a little spritz
and then you just spritz that on the
nuts
and you're off and running you're the
champion of your world with fine
smelling nuts man you don't want the
nuts of wand division episode one and
two you want the nuts of wand division
episode three and four and that's
what manscape provides probably not a
trademarkable
copyrightable slogan so we'll probably
let that die right here man yeah i'm
sure
disney and or manscape will be like
let's not make this partnership
on the vision
absolutely or just hex the hair away
with manscaped um the good folks at
manscaped
uh sponsor us tonight ladies and
gentlemen thank them
by going to their site and getting uh
the set
percent off uh and plus free shipping
with the code
fatman uh 20 all one word ladies and
gentlemen capitalized it looks like
i don't know if it's case sensitive but
you go to manscaped
m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d
dot com man it's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use the
code
fatman20 valentine's day man get those
i heart clean balls manscape.com there
they're gonna have that one for free
all right i heart clean balls
uh thank you to the good folks at
manscape for sponsoring
uh tonight's episode of fat man beyond
how you been mark i'm doing all right my
friend doing all right it's uh it's it's
been a it's been a week a good week
um yeah you know it's it's always hard
to say like how are you doing man well
all things considered i'm doing pretty
well what are those things
the world if you can just slide aside
the you know the sort of steady low
grade awfulness
of the last year you're in change
because we're coming up it'll be i think
march is like the full year of
living like this and so we're getting
there
we're getting there but i feel good
tomorrow being february 1st right
yeah yeah my god it is almost a year of
this lockdown stuff
um i uh i went out in the world to
this tour and yeah it just looks like
[ __ ] the walking dead out there um
you know not
because everyone's dead just because
it's empty it's so crazy it's like you
know we live in a
pretty big city you know a world-famous
city that usually has
traffic coming and going and my god it's
just quiet out there
um quiet like uh
perhaps west view new jersey uh let's
talk one division
before we lose everybody before we start
talking old men's stuff again and people
are like [ __ ] this
uh juan division episode four happened
on
uh friday ladies and gentlemen uh i
watched it uh
friday at 12 01 am as soon as it dropped
and uh let me tell you something that
was after a whole day
where my wife for whatever reason i
thought maybe she found out that i was
going to have another heart attack or
something like that
but my wife jem was just like um do you
want to watch a marvel movie
and i was like
[Music]
bought so i had to choose carefully
you know what you know it had to be
related to wanda vision which she has
been enjoying
so i had to go wanda wanda centric
movies
okay so at first i picked civil war
captain america three civil war which
she hasn't seen
so um you know i was like well you gotta
remember
she goes look if you're gonna keep
pausing the movie to tell me [ __ ] i was
like
when you question me i will pause it
because part of the fun of watching
those movies
second time is explaining it to somebody
else
so you know i was like i you know i i
won't
say anything unless you tell me to say
something and she was engaged she wasn't
like tolerating and [ __ ] and
every once in a while i had to be like
you don't understand me like you saw
end game and you saw like you know all
the heroes together but at one point
this was the most amount of heroes we'd
ever seen
in one movie and they were fighting each
other and she was like i don't like when
they fight i'm like good
because that's that's the way you're
supposed to feel so
she was like you know she's like i
really and did enjoy that man
she was like into it and stuff so
get some of that some of that ball
deodorant you hear so much about rub it
in my hands
works as a moisturizer just as well um
in any event she was uh
way into it and you know i was like this
is how you see this is like kind of
you know where things start to fall
apart a little bit for
the scarlet witch she's already lost her
parents she already lost her brother and
and you know age of ultron um so here
she's
you know now she's going to be a bit of
a pariah she got these people
killed and she's gonna have to pick a
side so i was like so you know you could
see
this all this stuff building up and
might make wanda you know snap or maybe
that's
she created all this maybe it's not
being done to her and whatnot
so she was into it and now she was like
all right what do you want to do
next because we still have two hours to
kill before
one division was on so i was like well
and then i was like i gotta be real
picky and careful
so how about we go for uh dr strange she
was like i don't think i've ever seen
that
cause i'm right on i said well dr
strange it's rumored
may appear in wanda vision coming up and
stuff like that
so um that might be a good one
so you could be familiar with them and
stuff who was this fellow you know she
said so
we start watching that she gets way into
it and stuff
she's a big fan of tilda swinton so you
know that
captured her imagination um and she
loved sherlock so cumberbatch
so she got into it and stuff and then uh
you know when it was over we had a half
an hour until
one division and then monovision episode
four opens
and spoilers ladies and gentlemen
because now we're gonna
we're gonna talk about it and if you
haven't yeah we're gonna go
we're gonna go in um
right away hands down my favorite
uh of the four episodes so far
uh they did not you know make you work
for it through the sitcom
suddenly and it's well designed well
crafted that way
they must have known that by episode
four we'd be like ah because
they literally address it like uh jimmy
woo's got a board up
with a bunch of questions that are like
the questions the audience
has had you know it's kind of clever
very clever like that
so this is the first episode where we
open outside of
uh the sitcom world sitcom doesn't
really come to play until
looks like about the very very end
instead
we find out more about monica rambo
maria rambo's daughter who we first met
in captain marvel as a little girl
and who we've seen in these episodes of
wanda vision
but now they gave us her immediate
backstory and placed the [ __ ]
series in a time so essentially we're
happening
after end game but before
or right around right before i got
spider-man
far from home uh is what the timeline
turns out to be i guess
because uh we saw monica
come back the blip as they call it the
marvel
universe itself we you know the snap for
us
when uh you know uh the hulk
snapped everybody back we've previously
seen reference to it in spa
did we lose kev
no that stupid famous person wi-fi
well i'll i'll pick up the ball a little
bit in that
and i will just cut to the chase because
i'm 100 sure
people are waiting for me to [ __ ] on
this because you know people think that
that's what i do
is [ __ ] on things uh but i will say this
um
it it not only did it give me what i was
looking for
out of uh wonder vision it uh
it i didn't even need answers because
this episode doesn't provide that many
answers just to provide you a different
point of view
and in that different point of view
you're getting this the sort of stuff
that i was kind of hoping for which was
here's a character that i can get
invested in here's a plot that i can
follow that i can track
and here are developments along that
that a answer some questions and b
completely open up brand new ones and
and so the sort of monica rambo story
um is the one that i that i'm interested
in now because and yes i understand that
wanda
i mean wanda and vision are title
characters of the show there's like
mark around though story um
maybe my back i think you're back
i don't i don't see me i see a weird
version of you and two screens
they oh my god i think i'm back
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened man
i guess i was just talking too much
[ __ ] zoom tossed me off
yeah that famous wi-fi dirtier than i
[ __ ] meant it yes my
famously bad wi-fi um
this was the episode where we got to
um meet uh monica and watch
what happened when she came back right
away when
the episode begins and all of a sudden
you're hearing her voiceover from
or not her voiceover but people talking
about her from captain marvel
dialogue and then you hear brie larson
you know call her like captain trouble
or whatever the [ __ ] lieutenant trouble
and then she wakes up and she's
unsnapping back in suddenly a story's
being
like told just like that and i'm leaning
forward and instantly i was like holy
[ __ ] and jennifer's like what what i'm
like
it's it's [ __ ] there it's the snap
it's like when
hulk brought everybody back and you get
to see the melee at the hospital and
then
uh sadly she had gone to sleep she felt
like for 20 minutes
while her mom was in the hospital
getting treated for cancer and she was
apparently
going to be cleared but then the nurse
told her like well that was
that was like five years ago and she
came back
three years after you disappeared she
came back with cancer and
and died so you know you get this kind
of bittersweet like oh man like she
missed her mom
you also you know get her going to work
and you realize that
her mom maria rambo founded uh seward
just like you know peggy carter was one
of the co-founders of shield
looks like maria rambo was one of the
co-founders of
of a sword which i guess has changed
titles to sentient weapon
whereas before it was something else
right yeah i
think so i think so but now it's like
sentient
weapon observation response division i
think
um but yeah and it is kind of cool that
you know
the the ladies of this universe are the
ones founding these giant
sort of you know pseudo governmental
law enforcement agencies um that is
pretty badass
and and yeah like you 100 are falling
into
the the her sort of monica rambo's core
problem her existence which is
her mother died you know she had this
job how do you slip back into your life
how do you sort of pay homage to the
woman who bore you
and continue doing the work and there
was that really great scene where she's
in
you know in that sort of quote-unquote
interview with her new boss the acting
director of sword
who was like yeah no this is just a new
protocol for people who repair it
and she's like oh well this sucks is it
just because it's me is it because of me
that i'm getting assigned to these
[ __ ]
you know jobs am i grounded on earth
because i came back and
the guy's like no you're grounded on
earth because this was your mother's
protocol she hoped you she banked on you
coming back
and as he said the one the one positive
was like she
she knew you were coming back she
believed you were coming back
yeah um they're telling us in the chat
tom c says it was sentient world's
observation and response department at
least originally in the comics
um now for this for the purposes of
wanda vision and going forward in
in the marvel cinematic universe it
sounds like it's sentient
weapons because the guy who's you know
her boss who wouldn't be her boss but he
is her boss because she blipped out
is explains to her as he walks her into
you know
the body of sword that um
they uh have grounded all missions
because you know because she's thinking
she's going to go to space and they're
like right now everything's
been grounded five years ago she was
used to going to space
apparently and now five years like after
the blip
they're not letting people go now when
he said like you know we're we're
concentrating now on the quantum and
blah blah blah
unmanned missions that smells like
fantastic four doesn't it
i mean it smells fantastic and also
smells you know quantum realm
van dyne you know kinds of [ __ ]
totally
it smells like they're sh they had shut
down
like manned missions um
and and now they're i it feels like
somewhere in there
it feels like the fantastic four lies
um whether it's like you know they're
they're not going to send them into
space
but instead go into the quantum realm or
whatever [ __ ] or
but it's it smells like
like it it seemed like an unnecessary
scene until you really started looking
at the dialogue
and then you're not an unnecessary scene
but unnecessary
dialogue until you really start thinking
about going like wait a second man like
maybe this is kind of just sowing the
seeds for like
what what is a manned mission for sewer
um and if so is one of those missions
send them in outer space as they've been
to outer space before this also kind of
points to i guess remember at the end of
what was it
uh uh spider-man far from home when we
saw
nick fury up on a space station
so i guess that's sword right
like well he's on a cree space station
right
but i mean it sounds like
last time we saw him with the with the
skrulls not creek
there you go the straws was in 90 in the
90s and then
in far from home his squirrel buddy and
the scroll lady
were pretending to be him and
and peter well yeah him and maria
meaning nick fury has been off in space
since he got back from the blip because
he wasn't
was he an endgame he's there for the
funeral
that's it right that's it which
theoretically that could have been a
scroll
um golf feels connected somehow
in the in the marvel university isn't
there like a satellite they have a
justice league
moon base or satellite khan isn't called
peak or something like that
could be that they're all [ __ ]
connected maybe that's where he was
because they haven't really explained
that part yet not at all
and it's unclear whether or not this
secret invasion tv show
we'll get into that because that's all
nick fury and the skrulls
which sounds like a a boy band from the
60s
the hottest boy ben no you mean the
skrills
so maria uh goes back to work at sword
and her boss is like nobody's going to
space but
we got something going on in [ __ ] new
jersey and
damn if my [ __ ] if i wasn't like
filled with jersey pride jersey
represent as i was like
it is new jersey like the [ __ ] things
taking place in new jersey man like new
jersey is in the marvel universe of
course
uh i mean and not the first time it
seems like we we come back to new jersey
more than once
that's true man remember like that's
where captain america trained and stuff
like that
so it was uh uh
you know they basically this episode was
them telling a parallel story
to the first three episodes that we
watched right and
how like monica wound up in that world
as geraldine
um she they brought her in to take it a
drone one
and go investigate and drone was kind of
painted like captain marvel colors
and she sends the drone in to west view
and the cops outside of west view were
like there is no west view
we're from east view but i never heard
of a west view
and then her drone disappears and she's
like that's [ __ ] up and
her and jimmy wu who was able to pull
the card
that was my favorite little thing nice
piece
of development nice piece of continuity
um you know she goes to touch the
anomaly wall which is static which
what they call cdmr or something like
that yeah or at least that's
that's what darcy um discovers some kind
of like residual
red radiation from the big bang like
everything vibrates with a certain
amount of
you know residue and radiation but
there's more of it happening in here
than there is any place else and then
there's also a broadcast signal that's
buried underneath that radiation which
is how she's the one who figures out
get me an old tv nothing with a flat
screen and then
darcy's the the wizard who gets us the
first views
inside westview we re-meet darcy
uh from the thor movies the first two
thor movies
um as she's brought in with a crew of
other people one guy is an ai
specialist which you would only bring
that in for what
vision because he's technically the ai
um and a couple other specialists and
whatnot and
she figures out like wait this cdmr
whatever it is
um that's the same kind of static that
tv throws off back in the day as well so
she pulls up in an old oscilloscope or
something like that
which just happens to be under the desk
in this age of high
tech in a yeah makeshift [ __ ]
like uh command center that they built
fairly recently but whatever
i'll let it go we always carry like 1952
rca tv set
just so funny like it's so funny how far
like i'll
like of course [ __ ] this is all
happening and of course she can
do these things with her powers and of
course [ __ ] you know dead vision
shows up
but it's so weird the hills that i'm
like
where would she get that why would that
old tv screen be under that desk that
makes no sense whatsoever mark right
it's like okay i get if this is at like
30 rock
you know and it's like i don't know we
had this thing lying around from when
[ __ ] johnny carson was broadcasting
out of this room
but you built with an entire mobile
command center and so
this was on the truck um do you think in
the writers room they were like
just who cares nobody's gonna bump into
that
if they do you know they get a no prize
bonus for them
um she uh gets to she's uh
darcy's the first one to tune in and see
that this
there is a sitcom happening so the
people outside of west view the sword
initiative the uh
uh command center are now like us
people who are like what what is this
you know so much so that they're like
this is a universe has made a sitcom
with two avengers and [ __ ]
like they have the same questions we do
they have figured out as much as we
figured out
like all right there are people who live
in this town and
they've become characters in this weird
show
if you look at the board of course you
know internet was alive with
hey man everyone's got a driver's
license except for
for uh for agnes uh who's played by what
captain han right
so naturally you know we've all felt
she's playing a larger role internet
seems to think she's agatha harkness
shortened to agnes who knows who she's
playing but she may be up to no good and
she ain't on the [ __ ] board
um we we uh
find out that uh monica has been viewed
in an episode that we didn't see right
so it communicates there are more
episodes of the show perhaps
yeah or at least this show is ongoing
like yeah it's it's round the clock it's
like [ __ ] cnn
of just what's happening inside west
view all presented as if it's a
sitcom of a certain era and darcy's like
how do they decide when to move from the
50s to the 60s or the 60s or the 70s
like does that
does that put some kind of prime frame
on it like how quickly are we
progressing
and then can you can you extrapolate
from that
once you catch up to present day that'll
be
thursday you know like but meanwhile
you could just turn on the tv at any
moment and be watching a version of this
show
the um inside they send another
agent inside the anomaly through the
sewers
in a hazmat suit but when he gets about
halfway through
once he passes through a wave of the
anomaly and his hazmat suit becomes the
suit of a beekeeper
the cable that he was on becomes a
[ __ ] multi-colored
70s kids jump rope and uh
that's what i got out of that and then
when he climbs up
we saw his perspective of that moment
from episode
was it one or two when wanda was
like no and it just went backwards um
you know so it's they're told this
wonderful parallel
story to everything we've seen so far
which was fun as [ __ ]
like never mind enlightening or at least
it was nice to know that everyone else
is as lost as we are
but just clever as well like you know
oddly function like a recap but like
from the other perspective very
rosencrantz and guildenstern if you will
so they uh eventually um
get to how do now how did they get to
how did they how did they get to the
like where they
um shifted to
oh they're watching the episode and
there's a glitch
like and darcy has caught this a few
times that there's a glitch there's a
glitch
and in the 70s episode there all of a
sudden somebody goes did she just say
ultron and they start watching the show
and you see what we saw on episode three
with wanda getting heated and stuff
and then over here because geraldine was
like why is she oh [ __ ] monica's there
why is she there
and then all of a sudden stopped and
jumped credits
to the credits you know and then darcy
was like that's happened before
and stuff and meanwhile the show took us
back to that moment from last episode
where we got to see what wanda did
to geraldine well monica by that point
um it got even scarier uh
you know um the scarlet witch got
witchier
she [ __ ] used her chaos magic and
[ __ ] shot
monica rambo through like one two
three walls and then the fourth wall
back into
west view or outside of west view into
the real world which was very cute very
clever
so that's how it ended last week with
her on her back and stuff
they came to her this week and you know
she was saying it's all
wanda it's all wanda um and then we went
back inside
and things got even [ __ ] creepier
when we saw the tail end of the last
episode with
uh wanda and the kids and vision comes
running in
to talk to her and he's like what
happened to geraldine she's like oh she
had to leave honey and
she turns to speak to vision and it's
[ __ ] dead vision from infinity war
man the one that
thanos had pulled the [ __ ] stone out
of his head and he went to gray
terrifying [ __ ] dead body vision and
they did a horror movie beat man where
you see like somebody [ __ ] not there
and then ah
and she does the look away and she looks
back and he's
totally fine and then he says like you
know
we could go anywhere you know we can
leave we can go anywhere and
very sadly she says no we can't
um which i don't know if that means
she feels like no matter where we go
there's [ __ ] tragedy or
we are trapped here and start
the former rather than the plan or it's
the
you know this is the only place you know
this is the only place that we can be
together you know
like you're not reading it i don't read
it as like i'm [ __ ] trapped here it's
more like
we leave here this all falls apart i'm
beginning to think
and i hope i'm [ __ ] right she is her
own big bad
she's creating this yeah it does seem
very much
that like jimmy wu and sword encounter
this already happening
like it's not as if somebody has put her
in this thing it's that this
this anomaly had already existed and
they're just catching up to it
and yeah just that idea that she knows
if we leave here
you know in this little bubble in this
little pocket universe that i built for
us
then you're dead and i don't have babies
and
i have to then deal with this so [ __ ] it
let's just stay
and vision looked scared like as
you know he's talking to her um you know
and she's like
don't worry i've got everything under
control dear and she's got that voice
yes dear
like very very uh
placid and we just saw what she's
capable of
in getting rid of my wife very several
wives and then they sit down on the
couch
for the end of the episode each holding
the kid and it feels like
vision looks dead into the [ __ ]
camera at us
like at one point kind of looks over her
scared and then just kind of looks at us
like
oh [ __ ] fantastic episode
instantly went back and re-watched it
you know at [ __ ] 12 30
you know until one in the morning
because this was
this this you know like i said last week
this is the [ __ ] show that i came to
see
and now you know they're they're able to
do an episode so good that it
improves the first two episodes for me
where i'm like yes
yes because they gave us some back door
information of what was going on at the
same time
which sounds sexier than i meant it so i
absolutely loved this episode man and
and even the wife
who again like nada died in the wool
marvel person like me but is now
becoming more marvel open and marvel
accepting and and counts herself as a
flat out wanda vision fan
she too was just [ __ ] like holy [ __ ]
this is good this is
this is now beyond fandom
this [ __ ] could work for like
people that don't know this world
very well they're telling their own
[ __ ] extended
movie the way you would go see it at a
[ __ ] theater and it's just we're
lucky enough to devour it in these
little chapters and [ __ ]
but it's working now like it's not like
it wasn't working before but holy [ __ ]
you could see it coalescing man and what
we keep hearing is the next episode is a
mind [ __ ]
like we're going to get a lot of
information the trailer for this next
episode shows like some [ __ ] in it where
you're like i haven't seen that footage
before what the [ __ ] has happened in
there
including vision like getting to the
end of the west view anomaly like the
wall that monica went through and stuff
so
i you know my only complaint about this
show
is that come on man [ __ ] fridays like
just
dump the rest man like it's
you know i know you got a plan and [ __ ]
and and i
i know it it gives us it teaches us
discipline
and you and i grew up in an age where
this was normal so i should be easily
accepting this but
i have not been this anticipatory for a
[ __ ] show
and since mandalorian disney plus
crushing it man
like if if they're if this is the future
you know [ __ ] it i'll live in my house
forever if they keep doing this and if
they keep handing off
one series to the next like mandalorian
ended and then [ __ ] wand division
started one division is going to end
falcon and winter soldiers starting and
[ __ ] that ends
they're handing off to loki man just
keep doing that
for like 30 40 years until i drop dead
that's all i'm asking like i love what
they're doing right now it's so
[ __ ] good and in a world where we
can't go enjoy a marvel movie at the
theaters and stuff like that and have
that collective experience where
everybody's going [ __ ] ape [ __ ]
remember the moment when [ __ ] cat
picked up the hammer and [ __ ] and
everyone was like wow like of course
in the age of kovid we would be super
spreading at that moment because we'd
all be like
so one day we'll get back to that but
until then this [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] fantastic fantastic
you yeah no i mean i i i
agree with with almost everything
no [ __ ] it i agree with everything you
said like i i've really really done this
episode
my only my single lone concern
going forward is i now don't want to
leave the monika story
because i think that that's really
important now once you establish that
like
i hope it finds a way to be telling
these two stories in tandem
the attempts on swords perspective to
get in and figure out what's going on
and want its attempts from within to
keep them out and to keep her little
pocket universe together
and then visions attempt maybe within
all of that who realize that
something's wrong in denmark something's
rotten in this particular
corner of denmark and i don't feel good
about this because it seems like he's
the one inside
who's scratching at the reality of like
wanda wanda wanda honda
you
um it is uh like
i i i i feel you exactly what you said
um i can't imagine
like you know we're getting even in the
preview for next week for episode five
we're seeing a sitcom like what looks
like the
90s sitcom um you know but we're also
seeing sword story as well
i bet you it is balanced between the two
at this point
god i hope it's what you said it is and
i've also been like you know of course a
lot of people
always like have been saying since it
began oh my god what if this is house of
m
and this is how we get mutants because
at the end it's a reverse house of them
and instead of no more mutants she just
says [ __ ] mutants or whatever [ __ ]
but kevin feige in a few interviews
recently
has pointed to not as direct source
material inspiration but
uh some form of inspiration tonally
for um for one division from that
20 what was it 2015 or 17 series called
the vision
that tom king did where vision created
his own family
like in the suburbs and then something
happens and he tries to kind of keep a
lid on it and how far will he go for
this family and stuff
and you know there's very little wanda
in it but apparently like kevin foggy
was seeing
like the covers of these books on his
desk and
it got his wheels turning
you know and kind of so even though they
didn't adapt that story
um directly there's you know as they do
with the marvel cinematic universe they
take flavors from a bunch of stories
that
you've read over the years and it seems
like uh the vision
has been served a bit as as deep
inspiration if not story
inspiration yeah and i believe it like
the same thing with civil war
you know like the civil war the comics
is fundamentally not the civil war of
the movies
but there's definitely some some source
material
um inspiration from those books to be
like okay well no it's not going to be
about a mutant registration act it's not
going to be about a superhero
registration act it's going to be
much more elemental but it's still going
to end with a big
fight between cap and iron there here's
uh
danny mirrorball and chad had this
[ __ ] thought and i i i
i doubt it but i mean this is the fun of
[ __ ] this imagine if this is it
he goes do you think uh chiwetel
uh how do you say the last name of four
year four
is the big bad he did say everyone has a
participate do you remember him at the
end when he was like too many sorcerers
when in the cut you know the the post
credit scene
doctor strange wouldn't that be amazing
if they [ __ ] it was [ __ ] mordu
against against wanda like i i i mean
my hat's off to danny for connecting the
two i don't think that's where we're
headed
but like they better not leave him
behind because he was such an
integral part of doctor strange and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness sounds like it's shaping up to
be this [ __ ] fun house ride and stuff
but there is the mordu story that they
still have to
[ __ ] go back to because i thought
that was dope at the end where he was
just like [ __ ] too many sorcerers
and the idea was he was going to go out
and start taking mountain [ __ ]
that gave me chills um this this cat
said here
i saw something that was uh oh they said
uh i
forget who it was i can't see it but
um the in house of them
wolverine was the one going around
waking people up
and they're saying vision is kind of
playing that role
it looks like in this one going forward
um to know if at some point
um jimmy wu now gets to be the next
person to go inside the sitcom
because monica can't go back she's been
expelled and wanda would absolutely know
that she's here
but to have to have you know sweet
randall park
swanning in there for the 80s which is
probably at the time where you have the
like
asian american neighbor to the white
family who lives next door
um on a sitcom that could be kind of fun
too like
give jimmy wu his shine um he he's shown
brightly in this episode
uh him and darcy uh two two
i mean would you call them third tier
fourth tier
characters from yeah you know from the
movies for their respective movies like
you know if
if thor you know is your top tier
and jane is your second tier
you know darcy's got to be well i mean
loki loki is
second or third you know darcy's kind of
like third or fourth in the movie yeah i
mean if selvig
is like third tier then darcy is like
exactly went from like comic relief to
major players still being comic relief
but like
how awesome that these shows allow the
to take characters that aren't you know
the big [ __ ] seven or whatever
and focus a light on them man like now
i'm sitting there going like
you know yes i want i want i want to
know everything about wandavision i want
to get to the end but i'm also like
i'll take a monica rambo show now like
let's go back to the movies what's she
going to do there and stuff
we know in the comics she eventually
becomes captain marvel who knows if
they're heading in that direction but if
she's
you know already got involvement with
space she has the line to her boss at
one point where you know he's like she
was like
they're all he was like there've always
been threats out there and and she was
like and friends too because she knows
the scrolls she'd come up with the
scrolls and stuff from the 90s
so same thing with jimmy wu man like you
know character that an ant-man
is like fun mini bite but suddenly
brought front and center and turned into
something even more viable and whatnot
it's so weird like
i'm sure kat dennings was like all right
well now that they've
you know gotten rid of jane forster like
i'm out of the marvel movies and
suddenly she's like i am [ __ ]
epicenter for like the next phase
and probably one of the most important
marvel projects like
since [ __ ] end game um which isn't
not being one of these broke girls
i want a job yeah man oh like
[ __ ] could you imagine like like i
in my world you know i call up people
after 10 15 years be like hey you won't
be in a jane zombob movie and they're
like oh yeah all right
could you imagine if you got called up
to be like hey man this is marvel this
is kevin feige
uh come be the lead in one of our
[ __ ] shows
like
what a dream um i look forward to with
uh great
anticipation and eagerness um episode
uh five yeah it sounds like we're gonna
get go watch that [ __ ] teaser
we'd share it here but naturally they'd
throw us off the [ __ ] internet i
don't know why we're not allowed to do
everyone else can do youtube but us
uh even on youtube and [ __ ] but go look
for the
spot that went up like two days ago and
it's kind of
four episode five um in promotion of
episode five if not the whole series
and it's a lot of like you know it's
called visionary it's a review spot but
they got new footage in it
that you know got me like
so you know now we're we've caught up
right we're starting to see all the
footage they've fed us for the entire
first
quarter of the campaign so they can't
keep showing us that stuff so now
they're going to start
adding on new with every spot and they
seem committed to making new spots every
week so
as somebody who loves to have [ __ ]
spoiled for him and whatnot
my wife's always like why would you
watch that we just see it next week i'm
like because i want to
[ __ ] know i need to know what i'm
looking forward to and [ __ ] like that i
need to
i need something to get me out of this
[ __ ] bed in the morning god damn it
she don't take too kindly to that but
now she understands
because she's a wand division fan just
like me um
i will say that that one division
episode four
was the second best thing i watched this
week oh [ __ ] what was the first
there's this it's it's the thing that i
don't want to describe too much because
the more you describe the
the the lesser experience it is when you
watch it but it's an hour and a half
kind of movie on hulu
called in and of itself it's uh um
it's kind of a one-man show um by by a
fellow named derek delgaudio
who's a magician i think by trade um and
a storyteller
at least to look at this at this special
but it's a it's a
filmed version of a stage show that he
put on for like
a year and a half um frank oz directed
the the the this version of it yoda miss
piggy frank goss
you order miss piggy uh dirty rotten
scout about 30 rotten scoundrels
um but i will say that it is
the most moving thing that i've seen
all year and i watched ped lesso which
was very very moving
um and as a storyteller it was
revelatory
and remarkable and i'm lit i can't say
much more about it beyond
it's a dude on the stage who
occasionally does magic but
the the key to magic is distraction and
usually a magician will find different
ways of like
moving your eye where he wants you to
move it and keeping you from you know
picking your eye off the ball so he can
do some [ __ ] to it
and a lot of times magicians use story
to help do that
but this guy deploys emotion as his
distraction
and also as the core of what this story
is
um i cannot recommend it highly enough
um it's an hour and a half out of your
life and you will be
a amazed by [ __ ] good magic and b
the stories he tells and the structure
he uses to tell it and the way he used
his magic
to amplify those stories is is
beyond belief so yes derek delgados in
and of itself
on hulu now it's an hour and a half out
of your life and it's
phenomenal like i can't i can't say more
because to say more would ruin it and
the less you know going in the better
experience you're gonna have
uh you're getting a lot of agreement in
uh the
talk back in the comments a lot of love
i saw one person being like it was
pretentious but everyone else is like
you're so right man
you gotta watch this thing yeah and you
know sure it's a little pretentious
because it's a one-man show which is by
nature a little pretentious
but still um it's it's it's profoundly
moving
and really entertaining and you know
i i would be lying if i said that i
didn't cry twice
if not really yeah yeah there's there's
a couple of moments that are just
shattering well now you have my
attention my friend i love
oh i'm gonna i'm an emotional [ __ ] i'm
a junkie for [ __ ] like
i listen give me a good cry
um i watched uh uh one night miami which
i thought was wonderful
um what a great director she is man
that's not the first thing she ever
directed i think is the first feature
yeah she's on tv she's got a great eye
uh what a great cast and that's my kind
of
thing man like it's [ __ ] all dialogue
like
four people in a [ __ ] in two rooms
like oh my god
like yeah dream project so that i was
incredibly well done
um what else did i watch um
god damn it i did watch something oh you
know what i [ __ ] i mean this ain't
anything new but
have you ever watched it's on youtube
this guy has a show
called all gas no breaks
no i i felt like i don't know
i came across and buy a vice vice had
done like a piece on
them and i don't watch vice very often
but it showed up in like my youtube feed
and you know i was just
stoned enough and like all right what
the [ __ ] and it was a fascinating little
piece about this guy who's got his own
youtube show
and has that for a few years and it's
just the kind of the piece on vice was
about his ethos how he puts it together
and um he's got him and a couple buddies
have like a
little camper a little mini rv or
whatever [ __ ]
and they just drive around and you know
this whole thing is like i just wanted
to like talk to
like real people and do stories and and
so
he got like a cheap [ __ ] suit from a
walmart like a beige suit
and he's got a microphone and he goes
out and interviews cats and
you know he's done places like a furry
convention
you know adult video news awards and
stuff like that but he's also gone to
like
portland during the riots and stuff so
you know you can tell when he's having
fun he's just wearing the
the beige suit and when he's gone like
you know to actually do some real
journalism he wears like this black
hoodie and stuff like that
but fascinating deep dive you know
some of the most of them are very fun to
watch
but it's what's what's been i mean his
style
is impeccable he doesn't like he
literally just puts a microphone in
front of people and
and maybe says one thing and these
people are so
[ __ ] happy to like
have a microphone or a camera on them
they start just giving content
one of the shorts was he went to a flat
earth convention
and i thought this was like fascinating
in all of the shorts
sooner or later somebody raps there's
always some
and it's generally mark i'll be honest
with you 99.9
of the time it is a white person like
desperate to drop
some some [ __ ] bars so it's crazy
every one of the shorts like somebody
like jumps in and starts
rapping and you're like wow who knew
very very confident generation mark
of of would-be young rappers who
see a camera and a microphone go right
to it um
so in any event he um he's talking to
like he'll sit there and and just
you know like somebody will come in and
say something
suggestive like you know uh hey man uh
[ __ ] but you know this will blow your
mind but it won't
get you blown blown you know
and then he'll go like his name's andrew
i think he goes
no i don't know what he and so he plays
it innocent
so rather than being like oh i know he's
just like what do you mean and he stays
in newsman mode
it's so [ __ ] entertaining man each
one's like
maybe 10 minutes max max so anyway this
flat earth one
was al all of the content all the people
he talks to i ain't judging anybody here
but i have i have
i've i very rarely see that version
of america like he goes to a [ __ ]
beach
where you know in the middle of the
pandemic and he's wearing his mask where
everybody's just partying
and they're all like white claw white
claw
like just screaming it and [ __ ] so no
judgment
if that's your thing that's your thing
but for me it's like oh my god like is
that what it's like out there are these
real people
so he talks to these flat earthers and
you know not for nothing i don't ever
want to [ __ ] on anybody's dream but
i'm relative i'm 99.9 sure that we live
on a
[ __ ] globe i've seen pictures you
know
the 0.1 that i leave off that's for in
case this is all a simulation
but one thing i'm damn skippy sure of
is the earth is not flat um
the rationale these people give they're
like or the [ __ ] design they sell
like maps that show a flat earth
with an ice wall surrounding the planet
that's what keeps the oceans level
crazy so he's talking to these people
dude
and you know puts a mic in their face
and they're more than happy to
espouse their flat earth's beliefs you
know it ain't harming anybody whatever
the [ __ ]
you know if you want to deny science i
guess that's harmful but
is somebody going like i think the earth
is flat has never really
challenged me in any way shape or form
they seemed harmless
every one of these you've got to watch
the short it is mind-bending
they start talking about flat earth
and invariably almost everyone he
interviews
in this flat earth short invariably
slides into this bizarre
anti-semitism where they blame
like the jews for for
keeping this hidden flat earth hidden
from the world
it [ __ ] blew my mind because i was
enjoying the short you know like oh
there's
these people are kind of kooky and they
go from [ __ ] kooky
to like scary and and [ __ ] unnerving
just like that so and he don't push him
i know these things are edited but
he does not he literally is just holding
a mic on them he doesn't even prod go
what do you mean by
them or something like that left to
their own devices they just slide in
that direction
it is fascinating to watch so flat earth
is the gateway idiocy is what you're
saying like you begin
there and it seems harmless it's like oh
no just dude [ __ ] i have this little
bit of weed
and then suddenly it's oh we're on like
hey hey
what did i hear about weed in regards to
flat earth
those two things they're not these
people
you end up you know just method clearly
that's what i was told taught in the 80s
yes yeah that part's wrong we nothing
wrong with weed
that part's wrong don't love me with
these people for heaven's sakes
it is fascinating all all gas no breaks
is what it's called i've been watching
that all week long
and then um i turned my wife onto i've
been it's been i've been a real youtube
guy the last week
um have you ever watched uh daily dose
of internet
i have not known they're adorable this
guy
he's been doing it for years and he's
got this like very monotone kind of
voice where he's like
hello this is your daily dose of
internet and he just
it's a collection of things that like
here's a video of people on a [ __ ]
cliff
way high up here's some drone footage of
beautiful setting
here's an animal doing something [ __ ]
funny it's just the best of the internet
and it's usually about four minutes
[ __ ] long and [ __ ] but he's been
doing it for so long that there are
[ __ ] hundreds of them and they've
also got compilations where it's like
two hours of daily dose of internet so
you know as we looked for something to
watch and didn't find anything worth
watching i was like
i got something worth watching and i we
went over to youtube and started
watching daily dose of
internet and my [ __ ] wife went nuts
dude i think i got laid off of this [ __ ]
she was so happy from it
she's like why have you been keeping
this a secret i was like i don't keep it
secret you don't
generally watch youtube with me or
something like that you always want to
watch like true crime programs
she's like this is so life-affirming i
was like it is it's fun
it's digestible it's quick you can go as
long and short as you want man
it's like [ __ ] you know better than
sex right and so we've been watching
that
and pigging the [ __ ] out man a lot of
eating this week
as we watch daily dose of internet and
[ __ ]
all guests no breaks and [ __ ] um those
those are the things that i remember
watching but now i want to watch what is
it called
the in and of itself in and of itself
and it's about hulu
yeah um that the flat out stuff reminds
me of a story
and i don't even know why but i remember
hearing a while back somebody going out
to
lunch or something something fancy
hollywood lunch with uh with 50 cent
and so 50 cents like yeah let me get a
grapefruit juice
and so then they just keep talking the
waiter comes over brings a grave to
grapefruit juice and 50 is like nah man
just [ __ ] pulled one over on me i
wanted grapefruit juice and the guy's
like well sir right this is grapefruit
juice
it's like nah [ __ ] you man grapefruit
juice this is purple
it's like grapes is purple the juice is
purple what is this [ __ ]
go get me some grapefruit juice it's
like oh 50.
i get it i did i did watch something did
you watch the denzel movie on hbo max
i haven't yet no it's on the list was it
called
little things the little things the
little things uh it's
relevant to our conversation and as much
as hbo max
is putting up new fresh new content this
was going to be a theatrical film
this is one of the movies hbo max is
like you know what [ __ ] it this year
everything that was going to come out in
theaters we're putting right on hbo max
or
i imagine it's also playing in theaters
simultaneously
i watched it on hbo max denzel
washington is fantastic
i will watch him do anything um
but it's him uh who's the kid from uh
ramy yeah rami malek from from uh
i was gonna say mr show mr robot um
and jared leto yes
here's why it's relevant to our country
is totally
fine movie's fun to watch through most
of it the ending
left me kind of like huh um but not bad
where i'm like what a waste of time it
was just not what i would have done at
the end and not what i saw coming
but i enjoyed the ride wonderful
performances watching three people
who are good at what they do do their
thing
this is not to slam uh jared leto
uh this is a compliment to jared leto
um i if he had played
the joker the way he played
the character that he played in the
little things
it would have been groundbreaking
like if he played a very unsettling
realistic character who may or may not
have been like psychotic or sociopathic
or psychopathic
and i was so impressed by his [ __ ]
performance somebody said he put on some
weight
he looked like he was wearing a fake
belly to me but somebody's like he put
on 70 pounds i was like that's what he
looks like with 70 extra pounds
but so he did a little bit of the
physical transformation
i think he had some fall season some
fake teeth i think because he had some i
don't remember him having
i mean jared leto is a [ __ ] beautiful
human being right like just
it's gorgeous to look at this guy you
know his he put some makeup on some bad
teeth
but his unsettling performance
like if he had done that for the joker
and suicide squad
would have like people would be like
talking about that performance and
with reverence hushed reverence i i you
know i
i was not um like i was not put off by
what he did in suicide squad i thought
his joker was a choice
and and at times fun to watch
but if he had done this oh they would
have given him awards he's [ __ ]
creepy
in the little things man and all i could
think of as he
as i watched the flick was like this
like that's your joker right there man
denzel is essentially playing old batman
in the movie
it's it's a good it's a good flick it's
worth watching the ending is a little
like huh
but i thought it was a good flick
excellent um speaking of hbo max
the trailer for godzilla versus kong
dropped
this week which made me
so happy
so happy haunted buildings kev again
what's good this is what happened kev
was reaching to tell me about something
that happened in the chat
and that cut him off stop looking at the
chat kid you can keep your wi-fi
he's back i'm back
well it was so funny because all the
last thing i heard was you were like
speaking of hbo max
and then you froze and i'm like no
i said um
the godzilla versus kong trailer dropped
this week um which is you know coming
soon to the hbo max
and i am all about that trailer i'm all
about that movie
as i stated on the internet i could also
be totally happy
with a 20 minute version of that that is
just monkey versus lizard
i wrote on your coattails with that
tweet because i uh
wholeheartedly agree as a kid who grew
up watching
the 430 movie and whatnot um you know
i've seen them balance the human and the
monster story for years
and you know in this age of the monsters
there's
no disrespect to anybody who acts in
these movies but
i you could i would i'd pay double if
you showed me the
20 30 minute version of that movie
that's just them beating the [ __ ] out of
each other
just giant special effects now there's
some people on twitter raise very
interesting points about how
godzilla and king kong were both human
stories
were created as you know allegories to
tell
larger stories about humanity um
in the case of godzilla it's about you
know
a man's [ __ ] mastery of the atomic
which uh suddenly could go wrong and
and whatnot and in the case of king kong
it was imperialism moving in and being
like hey we're here and [ __ ]
taking away people's way of life and
stuff like that human
allegory stories where the humans are
very important and you know i would
never say that
about king kong like oh you take the
humans out of king kong i just want to
watch king kong
i'd watch all of king kong especially
with the human parts
but in a king kong vs godzilla movie i
don't give
a [ __ ] about what humanity has to say
are you kidding me
i can watch human beings say [ __ ] all
day long
you know [ __ ] i got the internet man
i can watch people talking
all i want to see is the spectacle so
when i saw your tweet where you're like
i'll pay for the short version i was
like i want to live in your world mr
president president bernard
the world where they're like yeah you
can have the story if you're into that
[ __ ]
but if not here's the [ __ ] cut down
and we'll charge you more for it
same way like you know you [ __ ] go to
a restaurant and if you order
like fancy food which usually has less
like let's say you go to a vegan joint
you're ordering something don't have
meat and cheese meat and cheese are the
most expensive things
on a restaurant menu but somehow they'll
charge you more for giving you [ __ ]
less
i am willing to pay more for less man
now
it's hbo max so i'll be [ __ ]
streaming through
the human story if i feel the need but
just for going forward in this world
because the studios need to hear this
in a world where it's like i gotta make
a bunch of [ __ ] money fast
you could put out two versions of the
movie one screen has the two hour three
hour whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
the other screen half hour versions of
just all monster kick and ass
charge double and you're doing easily
three times the amount four times even
the amount of shows that you would
normally be doing with a two hour plus
movie
i guarantee you it may not be the
biggest of the box office
but there are a bunch of us that would
pay for that i know i'm arguing for
something we're never going to go
outside again by the looks of it and
[ __ ]
but if it ever happens and the studios
are like how will can we make some money
fast
like two versions of a monster movie
one with the boring human story
one all fighting action charge me more
i'm happy to do it yeah or like yeah not
for nothing but pixar manages to make
completely wall-to-wall animated movies
that are just about the [ __ ] monsters
so give me that like give me the raid
version of godzilla versus king kong
where the story is crazy [ __ ] simple
godzilla's coming to skull island he
wants something and khan's gotta stop
him
two hours later we have a winner we'll
need a lot of [ __ ] narrative
buffering to get into that i just want
to see giant things punch each other and
i'm
good i mean very simple
in chat victor venn diagram says so kev
wants the michael bay cut
of godzilla versus kong no that would be
confusing
i wouldn't know who was fighting who i
never know what's going on in those
michael bay movies
um what i'm looking for i think
is you know like because somebody was
like well do you want
somebody oh russell cook says a
compilation for monsters
yes that's what i'm looking for just the
the boogie night's cut
just give me nothing but the [ __ ]
money shots yet oddly enough i don't
feel this way about
superhero movies like i'm i'm more than
content to watch them
you know slug it out and [ __ ] but i also
love the human story
but it's just when it comes to the
monster movies like
[ __ ] a human story you know what i'm
saying like humans did their thing they
ruined everything and created monsters
there that's all i need to know
now i will say that they're like the
last godzilla movie that i saw
i saw on a plane which is this is how
long ago it was um called
shin godzilla and it was this really
interesting version of godzilla's
japanese
you know movie um but it's all about the
bureaucracy
that creates the lack of response to a
thing like godzilla
so it's both about you know there's a
[ __ ] godzilla monster that's about to
crush japan
but also we could have fixed this if
only we did the things that like this
one
sad functionary who's like 19 level
below
the [ __ ] president of japan or
whatever
it it's so [ __ ] timely that idea that
like
one guy knows exactly what to do and if
only we listened to him
we would be out of this problem way
easier with way less collateral damage
but nobody listens to him because this
is the way government is set up
and it's like oh damn i get it now
this virus is godzilla oh
oh [ __ ] um
so yes there's a way to make a human
story interesting it does not feel like
this is that way
in godzilla versus calling because every
line of dialogue is like
the dumbest line of dialogue i don't
wrote it my apologies i'm sure they
picked the dumbest lines for the trailer
i'm not sure anybody's work but there's
lines like
i don't know why they're fighting but i
hope there's a winner soon like
come on guys like i get it i heard there
was one line where he was like
godzilla's mad why is godzilla mad at
people
yeah godzilla's attorney people and we
don't know why i'm like yeah that's the
line
[Music]
i mean [ __ ] the trailer looks [ __ ]
great as long as you don't
as long as you look past all the humans
like [ __ ] duck kid
i can't see the giant [ __ ] titans
fight
um we got news we got some news my
friend
let's dive in let's let's see some news
let's meet green
um the the news at least for the week
for
me was uh netflix has announced the
first wave
of the cast of the sandman um neil
gaiman's
you know long in the works um adaptation
of his
vertigo comic book which is among
you know generously speaking like
the five most important comic books of
the last like
50 years is warner brothers involved
with this at all i know it's for
netflix like you would think hbo max but
neil owns the sandman if i remember
correctly
creator owned he was published by
vertigo
so you know he
he had the i think he's the one that set
it up you know he had had good omens
happen and then
he went to netflix and set this up but
it's it always struck me as interesting
that it wasn't
hbo max but instead netflix but i don't
know if warner brothers is involved or
has to be involved
in any way shape or form do you um dc
entertainment is involved they are
producers on it and they
but but it wasn't required to be
exclusive to the warner brothers or any
warner brothers outlet
even though they pitched it to him like
they pitched it all over the place and
when hbo and hbo max
at the time of the pitch passed on um
and i think
probably because it's crazy expensive
and at the time
hbo had been on the back side of game of
thrones and hadn't started hbo max yet
and it spent a lot of money locking down
talent
um you know they had to pay money for
you know greg berlanti to stick around
they had to pay money to woo
jj abrams and bad robot over so they
were spending lots of money going out
and they saw like well all right we can
either spend
200 million dollars making a netflix um
version of this or a streaming version
of this or we can make
100 million dollars because they'll buy
the rights to it and then we'll get a
chunk on the back end so they let it go
and then london and netflix um
the guy that they cast at least based on
the picture i saw
holy [ __ ] he [ __ ] looks he looks like
morpheus man or he also looks like a
young neil gaiman
yes and i think both of those things
look similar for a reason
yeah no doubt um who is that actor
um tom sturridge um who was on a stars
show called sweet bitter
i think i've never seen him before but
yeah
yeah he looks kind of perfect he looks
perfect uh
what's her name gwendolyn christie
mm-hmm there's a lot of she's
playing lucifer which i know some people
online were like oh man why not the
lucifer guy but
this is a completely different thing and
her playing lucifer is a great
[ __ ] choice oh well yeah like she's
perfect
she's perfect uh charles dance is
playing roderick burgess
who excellent [ __ ] piece of casting
right there but the
i mean i wonder how many episodes they
get out of that
ver that that part of the story well i
mean it depends on how quickly they're
moving through it because you know the
first arc
of the sandman is is sort of him being
trapped
by burgess and then later burgess's
sort of progeny um in an attempt the
spoilers gentle spoilers for a now 30
year old comic book
but um burgess was trying to trap death
and catch his dream instead and so
even though they can't master they no
longer have mastery over you know
the capacity to control life and death
on earth
they can still squeeze something out of
holding one of the endless dream
um captive and he does so for like 80
some odd years i think and so i don't
know
how much of that first season is going
to be that it doesn't seem like it wants
to be because you want to move on
to other stuff where green is not in a
glass bowl
for too long because that's a lot of
that story but even still if you got
three episodes of charles dance being
kind of [ __ ] great i'll take it
uh in chat they're telling us oh god
screw this says according to neil
dc owns the sandman rights not a
creator-owned project
uh victor venn diagram said there's
probably a profit share deal
with the ip sandman characters show up
in dc comics still
plus the lucifer show is based on
gaiman's version of the character
um then there's this weird thing here
where this guy's
nothing to do with anything but les ross
les ross says it irks me that kevin
still has not given his review
on the third season of cobra kai am i
alone
yeah you're alone didn't we [ __ ]
review kobe kai yeah he did it
sorry it irks me les ross that you have
not
watched that episode of me reviewing
season three of cobra car i gave it a f
i mean
long story short i gave it a big sloppy
blow job but yeah we talked about it
i mean yeah it doesn't surprise me that
that sandman because
it's based on a classic you know dc
character that neil came in and just
completely re-envisioned and rewrote and
re-um
imagined and i 100 believe that that
you know he has some control over it
because
dc would be idiots to not um to sever
those
ties because she is very much the keeper
of the dreaming
and so if if they do something that he
doesn't like
then it doesn't help them in any way
whatsoever
david dubois says i only reviewed two
episodes
of of uh cobra kai
like we spent like the front half of the
whole episode talking about how much you
love the third season
yeah i i mean again i love the whole
[ __ ]
i love that they went back to japan i
feel like we talked about all this
i'm not sure um philip dahl said this
kevin
if kevin is reading chap i hope he sees
that i love him
and love that he does the show and
introduce mark to the world
i personally didn't introduce mark to
the world uh
mark going to blame his parents for that
but i i you know definitely
put him in front of a microphone and
said say smart things god damn it
oh somebody wrote something called the
mordu theory mordo theory
malcolm harris says the mordo theory
mordo hates wizards so he imprisons them
in a version
of the mirror universe he catches wanda
to power it things go off the rails
everyone in west view is a wizard oh
could you imagine if it was that deeply
tied into [ __ ] doctor strange and
[ __ ]
that's crazy um michael albert says i
was going to look into cobra kai after
kev's bj the honest trailer made me
change my mind
um so apparently i did talk about it
quite a bit
yeah it doesn't feel like the mandela
effect of you talking about cobra kai
like no it existed it happened it's not
[ __ ] sinbad playing a wizard alan
padini says kevin i'm upset at you you
never read my comments
uh somebody else also asked uh let me
see well alan smithy says congrats on
staying with the quirky mercs that's
right i'm with the quirky mercs
for the shmo down uh i was uh there was
a draft
and i and i caught a draft no i got
drafted
and uh backed into the quirky merc so
this season going forward
on showdown i'll be battling with the
quirky mercs um
somebody asked about last week i talked
about motu and there was going to be a
masters of the universe thing
there was going to be and it got delayed
so hoping
that it's now this week uh instead
again not a trailer not footage
don't get excited but there is there was
a little something coming it was
supposed to happen friday
but uh it'll happen this week
instead i believe um so
yes something is something's coming but
meanwhile i've seen
uh oh let me see
six animated episodes already
um we mixed episode one
and we mixed two and three next week
it's are you doing that virtually what
is a virtual mix like
virtual mix well the first time we did
it so interesting that you asked
first time we did it it was a little
bungled because you're all on
zoom and already it's like the sound
quality is kind of bad and stuff
so i was like look do me a favor just
send me a quick time
and i'll jot down any any notes so i've
got the quicktime downloaded it they're
huge they're like [ __ ] three gigs
and um was able to watch it and then i
had very few notes and stuff the mix was
great
so we figured out now it's that's a
better
version rather than we all get on a zoom
and
you know you can't trust what you're
hearing and stuff um
we all get a quick time and we could all
me and the directors and
mattel the producers like rob and so we
can all watch it
and and take notes accordingly and then
just send notes to our mixer
and then he adjusts and so i was there
for like i only had five notes on the
last
pass of episode one so i was able to
kind of zoom in for that
to hear those five things and then give
it a blessing and it gets locked
but yeah episode one is is
completely locked like yes they're
starting to fall like dominoes which
means we're getting closer and closer to
people being able to see this stuff man
what are we we're just uh
february 1st is tomorrow
yeah it's coming soon kids
coming soon i can't wait and i'm proud
as [ __ ] of this thing
it's so good and i can't wait till
people watch it and everyone gets their
propers and [ __ ] you'll see mark's got
his own episode and whatnot
[ __ ] turned out so [ __ ] good in any
event that answers a question about that
back to you mark what news wither the
news mark
yes so the rest of the sandman cast um
boyd
holbrook um from narcos and logan
is playing the corinthian excellent
very good gas thing um vivian
um who i've never seen in anything but
using the witches
is playing lucien the chief librarian
and trusted guardian of dreams realm
instead of lucian which is lucienne
assim chaudhry and sanjeev baskar
are playing abel and king the first
victim and first predator
who are residents and loyal subjects of
the dream realm and i think this is
literally just part one
there's a whole nother um wave of
castings that will come because we don't
know yet who's playing
um yeah who you know i'm sure will play
a part in in season one
you think i mean there's a world where
they don't even get to death until
season two if he does the entire
roderick
burgess storyline they could probably
tease i mean it's not like
one issue evil equals one episode so he
could probably
pull the tappy and save death till
season two but
uh you really could yeah or you could
end
season one on sound of her wings which
is the first introduction
of death into uh into the into the
sandman books at any rate but i think
there's yes if this is gonna go seven
seasons which it feels like it could if
they wanted it to
there's plenty of time to get into all
of the the juice and joy of stuff that
happens later
they're gonna spend so much [ __ ]
money making that show it's amazing
yes yes they will so happy neil he held
on to it for all these years man
so many people have tried to do like a
theatrical version [ __ ] like that
and now it's getting the exact version
it deserves other people
took a crack at the script not even him
and [ __ ] and now i assume he'll probably
write all these episodes
well he's he's he's credited as working
on it or co-writing it with alan
heinberg
um who's the show runner alan hybrid
from wonder woman and then
grey's anatomy and there was a writer's
room so i'm sure that there's some
divvying of the scripts but i think you
know
neil could write as much as let him love
it as he wants to
and he is among the busiest people on
the planet so i imagine that it's like
i'll do that one i want to do that one
and i'll do that one and you guys are
the rest and i still get paid
uh bald bulldozer in chat says are you
gonna do your taxes earlier wait until
the last minute
damn ball bulldozer let's put it right
on brunch take us out of our
fantasy clubhouse make us think about
the real world paul bulldozer
i'll be honest with you somebody else
does that thinking for me
yeah i i i will i don't do my taxes but
there's an accountant who does them and
i have to give her
all of my stuff and i think that will
happen as soon as it can
because i just don't want to think about
it anymore a lot of people are asking me
if i'm wearing a [ __ ] kimono no it's
just a bathrobe
there's a bathrobe with a fat man beyond
t-shirt under it
come on they'd be wearing it come on i
know really i could belt that [ __ ] and
be like
no this is just a bathrobe a little
waffle bathrobe
probably came from the fat guy store if
i remember correctly
casual mail xl i won't give it up
i'll just grow back into it that's my
theory um
okay what uh what else we got going on
um there was an official announcement of
the release date of the snyder cut
um which we had always sort of surmised
it was going to be march
potentially early march now the real
real is
march 18th is when we get this so that's
when it happens march 18th one
gigantic [ __ ] four hour movie none of
this
mini episode nonsense one big meaty
all uncut cocked four hour
[ __ ] movie get your mouth and mind
around that ladies and gentlemen
they released some new posters they just
released a
he released an image today of what
looked like
cyborg taken off but it has a martian
manhunter quote on it and stuff
everyone getting way excited man we're
now a month in change away from the
snyder cut
indeed nothing will be the same no way
that will begin uh all the snyder cuts
will it'll open the floodgates of every
snyder cut the
the uh [ __ ] suicide squad snyder cut
jersey girl the snyder cut [ __ ] yoga
hoser is a snyder cut
everybody's just man you got something
wrong
i want to [ __ ] i want i want to go
back and find
my the preface that they cut off of me
at circumcision so i can have kevin
smith the snyder cut down below
it's a stretch yeah a little bit but it
won't it's all dry and nasty now that
won't stretch at all
no it'll roll back but i'm pumped all
right what else we got
um george clooney um fresh off the
midnight sky
has signed on to produce and potentially
star
in the tv version of buck rogers this is
good
[ __ ] news he would be an excellent
buck [ __ ] rogers man
this is a great franchise for this guy
to have
he's charming and buck rogers is your
charming [ __ ] leading man and [ __ ]
like that could be
all adventure i'm sure they'll probably
base it on the comic strips but they
could base it on the guild gerard
[ __ ] man
and be just just fine by me do you think
twicky comes back
um you know probably not but also
maybe because brian k vaughn is writing
it and like that dude is a deep nerd and
finding a way to bring wiki and dr
theopolis
back would be kind of amazing i hope to
god
clooney plays buck rogers that's amazing
fantastic casting
that instantly makes that must watch for
me let's be honest i was going to watch
it regardless but
clooney as buck rogers like i love it
i'm glad it's not some young [ __ ] i hope
it ain't some young kid i want i want
him
old man clooney as an adult [ __ ]
in you know space in the 25th century
doubling rp buck rogers [ __ ] a man
um all right what else we got um
did you ever get around to watching
titans
no to call you on the mat but oh yeah
have you i have not i saw the pilot and
haven't seen anything since but
they've now cast their tim drake um
we're titans fella named jay like hergo
is going to recur on the hbo max series
is tim drake who's described as a
streetwise kid who managed to grow up on
the toughest streets without losing his
indelible belief in heroism
that's not tim drake that sounds more
like jason todd
yeah well you know press releases right
he didn't grow up on the streets he had
a dad
he lived next door to bruce wayne he's
the one that figured out like you need a
robin
well it's like the mean streets of like
bedford
yeah if i remember my tim drake history
correctly i mean he comes about in
a lonely place of dying if i remember
right that's the first
tim drake robin story
um but he wasn't a street kid if i
remember correctly that was a [ __ ]
jason todd
remember like [ __ ] batman caught
jason todd stealing his tires i think
and then he was like why don't you be
robin he's like all right and then
beat him to death at one point and then
i guess he's not dead anymore now he's
red hood or some sort of [ __ ]
indeed not my world in my world
jason tied jason todd died when the
joker beat him to
has to matter yeah man and also
like we voted remember
yeah see mcmurray in chat says jason
todd was a street kid
tim drake is the detective kid exactly
he figured out
that batman you know bruce wayne was
batman and then he intercedes
um all right what else we got um
lovecraft country's creator executive
producer
misha green so talented that shows
what is she doing writing and directing
the next tomb raider movie
which now has me interested in seeing
the next tomb raider movie i was gonna
say yeah i've
previously was not that's not my scene
it will be the
lady who was in the last one alicia
vikander or whatever canada yeah
i mean so far she's she's set to reprise
the role and i
would wouldn't surprise me at all if she
had a little something to do
with uh with misha green's involvement
but bucket yeah and like
suddenly you've made it in some of the
episodes of uh
lovecraft country when they go on the
indiana jones
adventure part you know it's like
totally cut out for that
oh for sure for sure and so like yeah
they
it it happens very often these days like
same thing with buck ross when he first
talked about it we were like [ __ ]
roger's reboot
i don't know brian kevin's writing it
ooh way more interested oh
george clooney's gonna star 100 more
interested like
these days all of this is like just
reheating old ip
anyway and so the way you make a person
excited if that person is me
is put somebody really interesting in
the driver's seat and so for misha green
to be doing tomb raider [ __ ] it yeah now
i'll pay for that
oh man i want to watch it what else we
got
um a thing that i think um
fans have been wondering why it hasn't
happened before
seems like it's finally going to happen
in that harry potter will be coming to
television
and not just the movies which you could
have seen on the tvs
but the harry potter universe a live
action tv series
is in the works and could come to hbo
max yes or no i heard that this was
uh somebody said it and then hbo max was
like put the kibosh on it going that
ain't true or something like that
has this been verified well you know
this is according to deadline
that discussions are taking place hbo
max and warner brothers have come out
and said there are no harry potter
series in development at the studio on
the streaming platform
but that also smacks a little bit of we
are not ready to be revealing that this
is happening somebody spoke we shouldn't
have spoken and told a reporter a thing
and in the same way that like yeah
actors always will say i'm not going to
be she-hulk
and then that's lonnie and chihok
because they weren't ready to reveal
that yet
let me tell you kids if anybody could
[ __ ] if anyone could smell the
[ __ ] game
it's a guy who used to be in the game he
knows
he knows mark knows what he's talking
about man he knows it this does sound
like somebody spoke too
soon and then the the monolith is like i
don't know what you're talking
about no such thing not really
they'd be silly not to do some version
of it do you think
it's a reboot or like hey let's
or is it just we're going forward are
they allowed to go forward and tell
stories without
jk rowling um well i think that whatever
version of this
comes to fruition will be with her
blessing
if not her active participation and i
don't think it'd be a reboot
i think it'll be one of those you know
in the same way that fantastic beasts
is not about harry potter but it's in
the world it's there's a massive
wizarding world of harry potter that's
the name of the overall franchise
and so find a different story to tell
within that wizarding world there's
magic schools apparently on every
continent so pick a different school and
tell a different story
about those kids who go to the whatever
chinese version of hogwarts or
you know the fantastic beasts are set in
america so what is the american what's
the chicago
wizarding school look like um
one bay in new jersey i see no reason
why grover's mills could not also house
the magic school of america
[ __ ] i want to watch your show sign
me up man ashley collins in chat said
uh benedict cumberbatch batch is totally
not
khan remember remember when they told us
that they lied to our [ __ ]
faces and they're like he's not khan and
then he was
[ __ ] spoilers yeah it happens all the
time
uh what else we got um
i i like this one only because it's my
favorite headline
dr dre to star in the last voyage of the
demeter
um and it's not dr dre it's corey
hawkins who played dr dre
in uh in in straight out of compton
but this is based on a single chapter
in bram stoker's dracula novel called
the captain's log
and the champion there is there's a
russian scooter
scooter spooner named the demeter which
was chartered to private to carry
private cargo
24 unmarked wooden crates from carpathia
to london
and in those greats is [ __ ] dracula
and like
his coterie who were coming to the new
world
and so what happens why does this ship
suddenly come in it's a heart it's a
haunted house
story on a [ __ ] ship and so the the
the passage from carpathia to london in
which everybody on the ship dies except
for one person
that's the movie i'm like [ __ ] it all
right
like titanic meets dracula cool i get it
it reminds me of like uh you know um
hey let's do a whole movie about the
indianapolis story from jaws
like you know you could just section out
this thing and do a whole
movie about that like because in the
book
it's one chapter and they do the whole
like what happened on the boat and all
that stuff
a little bit but it's like you know
every night you know something is
stalking there's a presence on the ship
and when it finally gets and little
indians kind of affair
very much so you know and like smart
like pull a chapter out of a thing
that's in the public domain
everybody knows everything else but
there's just a separate distinct
narrative
right in this thing with brand new
characters that nobody's attached to and
dracula
you may or may not ever truly see i bet
you see him in the third act but either
way
super [ __ ] smart and apparently this
thing has been banging around for like
20 years
who's doing it um it's being produced
let me see
amblin is doing
it he's releasing
j scott for real suggested title
vampires
that's good
[Laughter]
good title man i mean you know that
communicates the story right there
vampire it's like star wars you know
exactly what you're getting they're
vampires
crossed with pirates they're vampires
then i saw a movie
during a shark week called uh santa jaws
and it's like yeah
no jaws is also santa claus i know
exactly what i'm going to get
dennis john based on mark's headline uh
which was dr dre
uh said it should be called straight out
of coffin
that's good very nice that's good
um ian mckercher says i've always wanted
a
jaws indianapolis movie featuring a
young quinn
yeah i'm with you i mean they've done
indianapolis
movies nick cage was in a straight video
version of an indianapolis movie but
like
you could totally like and you know who
could do it and should do it and i know
you don't ever want to like touch it
because like
you know it's his magic film but there's
a like why not steven spielberg do the
indianapolis movie
with the young quint character man like
that'd be dope
none of these i mean like enough [ __ ]
history movies
go back to jaws tell one more
jaw story could you imagine he was so
compelling
telling the story of one giant shark
eating people imagine he's got a whole
ocean full of [ __ ] sharks eating
people and [ __ ]
we get to see herbie robinson his old
friend from cleveland bob
get [ __ ] tom hardy to play young
quint
oh my god maurice the beast literally
just wrote the same thing as you said it
tom hardy
for young quint [ __ ] yeah
and kabuki says kid says nah don't mess
with jaws this ain't messing with jaws
they ain't messing with it it's just
[ __ ] telling a story
from jaws in the jaws universe
come on man oh [ __ ] on the parade who
said that
kabuki kid come on this is where we
dream
the real world they got plenty of people
that [ __ ] say nah don't [ __ ] with
jaws but here
we could dream about a quint standalone
movie
about the indianapolis with tom hardy
playing playing a young [ __ ] captain
quinn getting that accent down and [ __ ]
and it's also like really cheap when you
think about it because
there's you know there's an opening
scene when you're on the [ __ ]
indianapolis
it gets hit by a [ __ ] torpedo you
know
sorry uh two torpedoes slammed right
into our sides chief
that ship goes down and then you're in a
dive tank in front of a green screen
for the rest of your movie yeah
you can shoot that movie now in the
pandemic i'll tell ya
uh mike v says guys you are ignoring 30
coins best show on right now
i keep flirting with watching it so i
gotta
i gotta get in there man i've heard some
good things i finally started watching
um
casa de papel based on your
recommendation
isn't it wonderful it's really good i've
done like two episodes
um but yeah i and i needed that fix that
like heist
crime fix after lupine after i got to
the bottom of the five episodes of le
pen i was like oh it's right there it's
another foreign crime thing i'll just do
that now
oh and it's breezy and [ __ ] well made
and
oh so good what other news we got
the last bit of news is as is all too
often
the case um these past you know got
15 some odd episodes um is a uh
is a farewell r.i.p loris leitchman
yes the great and lovely wonderful
cloris leachman
um who has you know she was on tv
every decade from 1940 to 20
pens um she and she's tied for the most
emmy's ever won by an actor um
and you know she's also got an oscar
just a [ __ ] legend
um supernuts you know everything from
the last picture show
to mary tyler moore to phyllis to
malcolm in the middle to young
frankenstein to you just [ __ ] name it
she's done it
all the mel brooks movies [ __ ] facts
of life she came over and
took over for mrs uh mrs garrett when
she left
or yeah yeah that was right right
um absolute legend
um shane
um 94 94
i mean she was always working always
working
yeah yeah she was she was working up and
she was in american gods
um i think her last episode aired in
like 2019.
um and i guess working up until the very
end
god bless her yeah really man we hope to
have a career like that
yeah um cicely tyson also passed away
which hit us in our genre world but
i was a huge fan of busting loose like
when we first got cable tv the richard
pryor
comedy busting loose um was on ad
nauseum
so for one month straight i watched it
every day sometimes multiple [ __ ]
times
and um you know it's i'm sure some would
say it's lesser
prior but to me it's him at his absolute
best he's funny
but he's also incredibly warm-hearted
it's a very warm-hearted movie about
you know cicely tyson wants to get these
kids cross-country this inner city
school shut down they've got these seven
kids left that
nobody wants and she's like i could take
him out to my
mom's farm on my aunt's farm in
washington and so her boyfriend
gets richard pryor to like drive this
old school bus cross country
and um it's it i remember like it had
like
haunt i was a kid seeing it had haunting
[ __ ] in it
for a kid like there's one kid who like
was a pyromaniac
who burned his his house down and his
parents like died in the fire and [ __ ]
so he carries that around
like luggage and [ __ ] then there was a
young girl who's like who was
like nine years old she was like a
vietnamese prostitute so there's one
scene where she hits on richard pryor
and he [ __ ] freaks out at her
where he's just like you can't do that
that's wrong like he's playing a dad
type figure
so good but it's the one the scene that
like
still like i've stolen a version of it
and put it in jay and some bob reboot
um such a like a 1980s
cable scene to me because it was in
every trailer
for uh for bust and loose is richard
pryor is working on the bus
and um it's raining out and [ __ ] and he
can't get it fixed and so he goes
walking in the rain trying to
get some help and [ __ ] he's angry he's
talking to himself and [ __ ]
he says one of my favorite lines ever
said in the movie where he goes
give it a [ __ ] piece of push
because he's talking about pushing the
bus
as he's walking through the [ __ ]
woods in the middle of the night
slowly like from another path he's
joined by like an
entire coterie of the [ __ ] clan and
so
the clan you know come back to the bus
kids are on the bus and and they're all
telling stories and [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you see like the
fire reflected in the windshield and
and you know cicely tyson looks and you
gotta
in order for for this story to have any
impact whatsoever
you have to understand i grew up in an
incredibly uh
racism-free world because there were no
other
races it was a very white town and stuff
so
i learned about racism not from the
people around me but through television
and the movies and so her
reaction you know of course i was by by
the time i saw this movie i was like 10.
of course i knew the kkk was bad her
reaction though
of of like looking from the kids to
the you know the outside of the bus and
seeing this [ __ ] arrival of the clan
with torches
still haunts me to this day it conveyed
worlds of storytelling in one look
what happens is like the clan like comes
on the bus
partially and and richard pryor
sells him a line of goods on like all
the kids are blind there's one blind kid
in the group
and he grabs the clan guy's hood and the
guy's like oh are you doing and then
richard pryor is like they're blind
they're all blind
i'm taking them to the ray charles
school for the blind they're all going
to get operations and stuff
and so he like [ __ ] plays on the
dude's sympathies and the dude's like
well we'll give you a push
and they're you know [ __ ] if only all
racists were this simple
and and stupid in the real world that
could easily be turned around and stuff
and so they push the bush they push the
bus out of the mud and they fall in the
mud the bus goes [ __ ]
sailing away they don't stop to be like
thanks
but the reaction shot of richard pryor
and cicely tyson when they're [ __ ]
pulling away
like both of them in near [ __ ] tears
i think they both have glassy eyes
and just the relief and an overjoyed
uh reaction to being free from
you know potential [ __ ] harm like
conveyed an awful lot to a young white
kid in the suburbs who was like oh
[ __ ] that tells the story and that is a
very fun movie as well
don't get me wrong but like powerful
[ __ ] in the middle of that funny movie
that movie is
baked into my creative dna like you know
it's not enough to just be funny i also
want to like tell
a story or move people at the same time
and that movie does that
still to this day when she passed away
at age 96
it was just after she released her
[ __ ] memoirs um
you know i was like oh my god like i
haven't thought about busting loose in a
while
and i went and [ __ ] bought it and
[ __ ] didn't even rent it one bought it
on itunes and watched it again
and it still holds up you know it's very
late 70s early 80s and stuff like that
everyone's certain certainly dressed the
part
but it's it's that movie still holds up
you could totally remake that movie
today
and it would probably still work but
they did such an amazing job she is
fantastic in the movie if you've never
seen busting loose
it's it's worth a watch a lot of people
watching this show probably never even
heard of it [ __ ]
fantastic um that's all the news we got
that's the news brother that was the
news kids
uh the thank you to mark for collecting
that news for us
um otherwise we wouldn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on in the world
um we are going to do uh q a but first
we're going to
uh take a minor break jc did you get
did you get an ad yeah i've got it i can
i've got it all set up
this uh number one is twofold kids it
helps
of course me potentially sell things but
more importantly this gives me an
opportunity
to smoke a joint something i'm not
allowed to do on the facebook version of
the show apparently
and then head into the questions
completely refreshed
and ready to go so it's about a two
minute and change
little commercial don't go away we're
coming back to answer your questions but
this is a little spot
for uh that kevin smith club man if
you've been holding on to
taking a leak go take a leak now if you
got it
[Music]
i do
[Music]
hello what club
[Music]
hey man i'm kevin smith and if you're
like me you love
oral and you love hours of it pulled
long like taffy right man well i got
lots of world because i've been
recording podcasts
since 2007. it's time to take the gloves
off ladies and gentlemen
and let you have a crack at it by
joining that kevin smith club there's
four
tears you just want to hear my voice be
a clerk you want to hear my voice and
see me
be a mall rat you want to get some
merchandise like pins
or scripts be a fun employee or a yoga
hoser
it's a place where we're going to park
the entire smartchive man
all that shit's not exclusive enough we
got three more shows that are
only gonna be going on at that kevin
smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years wake
and bake with kev that's right a video
show where every morning whatever i'm
doing while i'm smoking man you're gonna
hang out with me and then of course
the exclusive kev cast man that's the
podcast of me just by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
then there's video we got hundreds of
hours of unseen video
are you even supposed to be here today
well find out by paying five bucks a
month to become a clerk
get you access to ad-free podcasts plus
it lets you join that kevin smith club
discuss board man where
once a month we're going to have a big
old gathering now for 10 bucks a month
man you could be a mall rat what do you
get for being a mall rat
you get all the video shows man all the
video and the video archive and we got
hundreds of hours of stuff
that you're gonna be able to watch for
15 bucks little man you can be
a fun employee in that kevin smith club
you'll get everything the clerk gets
everything the mall rat gets plus you
get four pins a year man
they said i was crazy for making yoga
hosers so guess what our highest level
is the yoga hoser for thirty dollars you
get everything the clerk gets
everything the mall rat gets everything
the fun employee gets plus
four times a year we're going to send
you an exclusive
mini script that's right look at this
script man this is the clerk script from
second draft january 1st 1993
pen and ink revision man we're making a
copy of this
you're going to be able to have one but
if you can't join that kevin smith club
don't worry about it spodcast
hollywood babylon fat man beyond they'll
all still be free from now until the end
of time
but if you want to be involved in the
least exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club man
now's your chance to club kevin smith
all right kids we're back um
a lot of feedback was people going like
are you [ __ ] me did i just watch you
fellate a [ __ ] microphone
hell yeah you did didn't cost you
nothing either
it's free that kevin smith club go to
thatkevinsmithclub.com
um i was watching the spot man i shot
that
one year ago really somebody was like
look at your tan
yeah i was back world i used to go out
in the world
i was just coming off of tour man we
went around around the country with the
flick
so i would i would go outside
unlike nowadays um all right
we're back kids um and this is the part
of the show where you
get to play a part three years are gonna
ask
something um and we're gonna give
answers to the three of when we used to
do this
at scum and villainy cantina jc's
watering hole um we would give out
prizes remember
those were the days remember uh [ __ ]
uh what was the
the uh uh movie theater thing
um
um and then what was it remember uh um
we all went to see spiderman but it was
not 40x it was something else
screening screen x screen x but they're
both the same company
and [ __ ] deacon always giving us tickets
to give out that was so sweet and then
we'd give out
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] man you know posters
and just [ __ ] swag that would come in
and
i missed that i miss uh i mean of course
we all miss
what we used to have and stuff but you
know the the
intimacy of that 70-seater
and familial faces there's a room so
small you can see the same people
over and over again right ahead of us
you know there'd be
uh cat ears [ __ ] nate and [ __ ]
shannon like one day we'll get back
there
jc how goes uh how goes club land
um well they just reopened
outdoor seating for restaurants
in la uh friday but we don't have
outdoor space so we're still closed
but hopefully that's a good sign
hopefully it's not a sign that
lots of people are gonna go out and
spread covet and we're gonna have to
lock down again
yeah yeah but i did see like some
footage of like beverly hills eateries
that were just packed to the gills the
first weekend
and it's like yeah guys i get it but at
the same token
maybe don't the outdoor eateries yeah
but you're not as crowded as they were
inside i just like
like i don't know i just i i don't like
i
look i want things go back to normal too
but i'm not like
like i never liked eating outside when
we could eat
outside you how every time here in los
angeles they got some places indoor and
outdoor
and you know they bring into a place and
like you know i'd be like can we sit
inside
and my wife would always be like what's
the point of going to a place with a
lovely garden if you're not gonna sit
outside i'm like all right they got bugs
out here
like i came to the air conditioning
we're meant to be
inside eating and [ __ ] um i'll wait
until they let us go back inside
and even then it's gonna be i don't know
man it's gonna be
it's gonna be a while before i'm like
comfortable enough to take that mask off
in a closed in-room setting you know
what i'm saying
and then start taking [ __ ] into your
mouth that sounded hot dude
say that again turn the lights down be
like i'm taking [ __ ] in my mouth
do
let's put a [ __ ] condom on that
microphone like we just saw
batman funny man's keeper jc
what uh who wants to know what um
our first one is from jessica nicole who
was
curious who the first mutant you would
want to see
in one division would be
what a great [ __ ] question
number one number two a girl
it's always such a sausage party up in
here man like it's nice to know that
good for you got a question in welcome
um okay
well none of the ones we've seen a lot
of for like
a decade right so you know they can
they can keep magneto on the bench for a
red hot minute
unless they're playing him as her dad
like
if we're finally getting magneto who is
wanda's father
as in the comics then give me magneto
all day long
um i don't know if you saw but there was
a leak
a leaked image from next week's episode
that i did not see but i read people
talking about mark
and it featured
um it featured an actor
who plays a character we all know
uh magneto as the dad was retconned in
the comics like so what they don't do
that anymore
well i think that was the right kind of
comics i think like eric lyncher
was never initially wanda's dad
but later on they dovetailed it in to
make it that way
do you think that was chris claremont
probably did that um
maybe it feels like a claremont thing to
do you know or it feels like a [ __ ]
grant morrison thing to do
jeffrey chim uh in the in uh chat said
the leak is from
episode six um
so i don't wanna you know what we won't
touch that but did you do you know what
i'm talking about did you
i didn't because i've been trying to
stay pure
although there's a lot of talk about um
you know one actor who has been in
previous x movies as a particular
character
who may or may not be on one division
that kind of blew my mind man mariko
gray says do you think the cmbr cosmic
microwave background radiation
is a sign of the reverse house of m
where it's released from westview as
well as fantastic four that's what we
were talking about earlier in the show
they have a line in there no no lines
are thrown in
without purpose and there is a comment
about like this is the stuff that's been
around since the big bang
indicating that cmbr at least the
purposes of the marvel universe is
potentially world building material
perhaps that's what her chaos magic
is made of or something like that but um
yeah hold on blake matthews says john
byrne made magneto wanda's father
and she's and he still is in the comics
right they didn't retcon that out
they're still related i think so
but i couldn't be sure so which mutant
would i want to appear
who is not the mutant that you may or
may not have seen pictures of
on the internet um
i mean i kind of i kind of want i kind
of want namor
to be that person is a mutant
him as a mutant still i i i mean i think
he was the first mutant
um so it would be kind of telling if
neymar is also the first mutant we see
in the new mcu
although it seems as if in end game they
imply that there's already underwater
tectonic
activity off the african plate which i
think was supposed to be
namor so maybe not
[Music]
um hmm
who do i like who would i like to see
um
night crawler i mean we've seen a really
good version of nightcrawler though
like so i should be going for a mutant
we've never seen but like what mutants
didn't they do
we know would be interesting i wonder if
uh emma frost
because it feels as if a character like
emma frost would actually be at home
in a weird sitcom variation of the world
yeah i wonder if you've already met emma
frost and they used her as but more of
as like a
you know henchman sidekick right
whereas in the comics she's like
generally in control
um i wonder if yeah
honestly like i think i know it's not a
like a sexy answer but i would like her
to meet professor x
and i would like it to be [ __ ]
patrick stewart sir
you know sir pat um
he don't have to be the charles xavier
going forward but it sounds like in a
world where they're doing multiverse
like [ __ ] that'd be a mind-bending
character to throw in there but still
hold on
kitty pride she was my favorite mutant
when i was a kid
she could have locked me with her
yeah can't give her some little girl
just playing on the street with like her
pet
on west view and it turns out that
that's like a kitty crime
that would be bad um
[Music]
kevin is missing mark's point about emma
tj monroe says
do your point about emma i wonder if
we've already seen
emma frost and i wonder if that
person is being played by the woman who
was supposed to be our guest today but
wasn't
and so if emma caulfield is actually
playing emma frost within the show
i mean just because they have the same
first name
no no but no
i mean it doesn't hurt but
that's sort of imperious in control over
everyone and everything
plus platinum blonde um helps
um let me see
all right
count morbid a live says mark
interesting theory
well thanks count more better lives
hulk's hemorrhoids says
uh giancarlo esposito as magneto
i mean i'm all for it but also because
it rhymes
like i never knew i wanted those two
names together man
no more i mean uh all right that was a
good question
yeah if it uh satisfied the
responses but you know i would also like
to see
i i'm hoping to god they bring her
brother back for something
you know they haven't mentioned that guy
yet but
and if not their brother that we saw in
the marvel cinematic universe
evan peters version from [ __ ]
x-men that'd be badass yeah all right
she pulls a different pietro out of the
multiverse
i throw up the [ __ ] chaos magic horns
for that [ __ ]
um all right man that's question one
down jc
come on back and tell us what they want
to know for question two
uh harvey glassman has an interesting
one
okay he wants to know what would be a
good dumb
superpower uh he says i shoveled three
driveways today mine would be a tiny
flame i could shoot from my feet to melt
snow as i walk
so what would be like like you're the
crappy
mutant superpower
uh command over keyless entry
so you know you know how you got to
click your car
to just be like this and it goes boop
boop
um you could keyless entry your house as
well so you just wave a hand
that's mild and useful
and really helps only yourself you know
like even heated feet
which will help clear the driveway
conceivably could be used for the
i guess i could help people get in their
car yeah i could be like
i got locked out and i don't have a wire
hanger i'm like oh
so i could be useful as well your
superhero name would be locksmith
which works twice am i wearing a mask or
no
hmm no well yeah you're wearing like a
domino mask
and right in the middle is just the key
so maybe it's smart
to have my name sound so close to my
superhero name because i'm hiding in
plain sight
people like it can't be kevin smith he
would never
choose a name with smith in it like
he's still wearing that purple blazer
yeah isn't that that white hat he's
always wearing
he's just got a domino mask hey that is
kevin smith
all right you got me i got the power to
low-key open locks man
keyless entries are my specialty that's
my ability
um what's yours mark um
part of me wants to be like the mutant
power to know exactly when the popcorn
is done like
not one kernel wasted not one second
longer nothing's burned like always
perfect popcorn
like it's only helpful once every like
eight days maybe and you know but
you would be thankful if that person was
in your life because you then don't get
a bag full of burnt popcorn or a bag
full of [ __ ] kernels nobody wants
that
let me tell you something right now you
made me want popcorn suddenly i was like
that sounds [ __ ] good
so i think your low-key mutant
superpower
is the ability to to suggestion
power i'll take that that would be mine
power of suggestion man where you can't
change people's mind but you can kind of
set them in the right direction where
you're like
you know [ __ ] don't get the pancakes
and they're like i don't think i am
getting the pancakes
and that changed their [ __ ] life all
the way through or whatever super low
level jedi mind trick like i can't
make you do like [ __ ] you wouldn't do
but i could help you do the stuff you
want to do
i like it um all right i once wrote a
comic book i once wrote a short
for marvel um called one night only
and it was about the one night a year
when wolverine can get drunk
because historically his mutant power
his healing power counteracts the
alcohol inside of every alcoholic
beverage so that he can never get drunk
but he used cerebral to find a mutant
whose power was to
dampen your mutant power but only within
like a six foot radius
that's all that he could do and so once
a year he would go out with a guy named
chester and go and like buy one on
and chester just worked at a [ __ ]
best buy because that power isn't useful
for anything
he's like i can make great sandwiches
well thanks you know chester but that
can't help us beat up magneto
um but it was just like one night where
wolverine can get like really rip around
drunk
and like get into a big ass [ __ ] bar
fight and then feel it all
and then he just drops chester back at
his house and goes about his life
i like it i come up with a new one ready
um the the mutant ability to
spontaneously give orgasms without
touching
wow
that would be that you could de-escalate
any situation
even if say somebody was like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you and you're just like
blank
and they're like oh
both of those the guy who can dampen
mutant power
and the orgasm would be great in a
three-way
with gambit and rogue
you've been waiting your whole life
you've been trying to find the perfect
circumstances by which you could have a
three-way with rogue
and not get hurt you can't do it man
with rogue you can only look it's only
hover
you know it's that kind of [ __ ] you
can't touch because the moment you
connect
she's sucking out your life energy and
stuff yeah so like this guy gets to be
the cut
in every relationship with rogue and
somebody else just
you sit in the corner i'ma go do some
[ __ ] over here you make it all good it's
like
can i can i be nope you can't touch no
no lookie no touchy i like it
yeah and you like that like you'd have
to be a cult leader like if your powers
are just like dole out spontaneous
orgasms with like a blink of your eye
then you can make people do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do like suddenly you're
like
think about it yeah you could you could
it's a it's a sellable
mutant power as well because you could
like set up shop like lucy
with psychiatric help booth you know
[ __ ] the doctors in
quick nut for like what's a good rate 50
bucks
that seems steep yeah but you know the
best things are mark
number one you know you're not uh
married people can use this service it's
not cheating
um you don't have to go out and find
somebody you're not swiping
either way um you don't now in this
covet era you're not
it's contactless um so it's worth it you
know how like we pay a little more when
we have food delivered to the house and
[ __ ] and you're like well you know what
at least i'm not going out there it's
worth it
i think people would pay 50 bucks for it
for a [ __ ] insta orgasm where they
don't get touched or anything like that
i feel like there's also a world in
which i remember reading an esquire
story about some dude who heard
that frank sinatra would tip everybody
20 bucks
no matter who you were no matter where
you were um if you if you picked up his
if you validate the car 20 bucks maybe
it's 100 bucks i don't remember you
he called it duking and i think it might
have been a hundred dollar bill
and it's like how much of an economy can
you create if you just tip everybody a
hundred dollars like what
what what how does that change your life
if you know the dude is checking your
coat 100 bucks the waiter 100 bucks the
major d
100 bucks like is it doesn't make
everything awesome
and like you could create an entire
economy based on
you know spontaneous orgasms like you
don't need money anymore if you're this
dude
just hey i'm gonna zombus can i just
have my car back oh yeah no
i could give you a tip or i can give you
the most mind-bending orgasm you'll ever
have in your life and i won't even have
to touch you
like i'd say you know i i on a whim i'd
be like all right [ __ ]
let's try it let's see what happens all
of a sudden like you're hit with this
[ __ ]
body wave like i generate i'm like and
it just generates a body wave that
[ __ ] hits you and it's
it's like it's you know it's like it's
like an
insta [ __ ] hit orgasm and then it
ends with like a piss shiver shake
your sidekick would be your sidekick
would be
uh the guy who can pull moisture right
so you get him there
and then he cleans them up and then you
send them on their way
come eater that's my sidekick
become eater and they don't mean that he
literally like each come in front of you
that's well
you could pay him and that's way more
expensive that becomes a whole kink
but come eater's job is to just like jay
say
jc says microwave the [ __ ]
audio and stuff yeah you can put that on
for an extra it's 50 for the [ __ ]
insta orgasm
and 20 on top for
the cleanup some people don't choose to
clean up like 20 bucks i'll clean up my
[ __ ] self i'll get a paper towel
but you know some people go for the full
nine because they're like
it's under a hundred bucks i'm gonna
have a mind-bending orgasm and have
something to talk about with people and
[ __ ]
yeah dr feel good and squeegee coming
your way
uh fat black patrick swayze chimed in
and said the
the name would be the sidekick name
would be the dry cleaner
the dry cleaner i love it that is good
yeah ankle bird hunting and the dry
cleaner
kevin uh beau chauvin says the power to
smoke weed on facebook
[ __ ] hear you man
what's with mark zuckerberg man like
come on
um all right that's two what is our
third
question of the night okay i really like
this one this is uh
j scott for real uh says in honor of
groundhog day
if you were stuck in a time loop uh
what movie day would you want to exist
within
what a great question
all right let me think about all my
movies no
no i mean i don't know mall rats might
not be a bad day to get stuck in that
all takes place in like mostly in a day
right and like
you get to meet stanley over and over
you get to go to the mall
nobody's wearing masks [ __ ] there's a
game show
you know you could probably like the
results of it can change each time and
stuff
chainsaw bobber there oh my god yeah
trap me and mall rats
eternally over and over again
that was a pretty good time in my life
in real life
and in the movie itself so i'll take
that
a movie day
i keep i keep going back to ocean's 11
the day of the heist where
like you know what you're you're doing
something you're doing it well
everything is going off without a hitch
you get the girl
and you get 11 million dollars and you
know you've succeeded beyond your
wildest dreams
you've made the bad guy look like an
idiot and you got to do it with your
friends
like that seems like a good day
ferris bueller's day off that's a good
day that is a good day
you get trapped in over and over again i
mean but then the you know the [ __ ]
you got to deal with cameron over and
over again as well
yeah the camera's such a drag
in my rats you also leave the mall you
get to go to the dirt mall as well
so there's that i'm sure um
let's see
i mean well not not breakfast club
because [ __ ] detention
it sounds awful yeah and also there's
only like
[ __ ] four other people you get to
know them real quick after one day
um hmm
no i stick by my answer i'm gonna be
trapped in my if i have to be
we try i'll groundhog day and mall rats
and stuff
jason you got one somebody in in the in
the chat
there's a few people saying debbie does
dallas yes i guess a sex orgy would be a
thing to be
trapped in over and over again bernie
lucia says saw
five bernie you need to see a doctor bro
yeah i don't know this is fantasy man uh
devil's advocate production says have
you all seen
batman soul of the dragon i am watching
it this week have you seen it yet mark i
have not known
that is our assignment for this week
aside of course from gathering next
weekend to talk about
latest wanda vision we should watch
seoul the dragon
because it looks fantastic i'm making
i'm making that
the time
um i feel like you could get trapped in
like the last day of the wings
just before they die like hey we're
going to the movies
slash opera wouldn't that be great and
then you end there
like if you just got to do that [ __ ]
last day as a spoiled rich kid who gets
to hang out with his folks and go to the
movie slash opera
and they don't die but let's pretend
they die at 1201
that's true so that would be his
favorite day but not mine
i don't want to be [ __ ] trapped in
bruce wayne's best day and [ __ ]
i got a parent on my own
feeling like an awful thing though no no
i know and as a batman fan it'd be nice
to watch like you get to sit different
places in the opera and you're always
looking at
him having a good time with his [ __ ]
parents and [ __ ] or opera that's in
[ __ ] the movie he'd be going to see
zorro right
yep so you get to see zoro a couple
[ __ ] billion times and [ __ ]
you sit wherever you want you think of
all the popcorn that's when you want
that mutant ability that mark was
savoring so much
because you're going to be eating a lot
of [ __ ] popcorn it's that
you go get it superman
uh you know uh his first night in
metropolis
although that would be seeing it from a
distance superman like you know when he
takes lois out flying
that wouldn't be bad to be trapped in
and [ __ ] i mean not for nothing but
groundhog day itself doesn't feel like
the worst day
true you get to hang out with bill
murray over and over again you probably
become good friends
and then you can tell and you get to go
to a party you get to eat lots of
breakfast food
you just gotta dodge needle ned ryerson
but other than that
and maybe you don't pay attention to the
homeless dude who's about to die orion's
angel
said career opportunity to be stuck with
jennifer connelly and a target
um speaking of jennifer conley number
one great suggestion
number two uh as everyone watched uh
episode one of season two of snow
piercer
just came back man and they brought in
sean bean as mr wilford
sheen bean they're off to the races man
uh diego the don 22 says days to confuse
trapped in that day
it's not a bad day they did some [ __ ]
not a bad day you know
um uh not uh
here's some here's some days not to be
trapped in river's edge
uh stand by me
uh deliverance yeah
well like the opening part when they go
fishing i guess if you're into that but
get out quick
um what a good question man so fun uh
was that was that
it that's three what about risky
business
which day the day he opens the brothel
the day he opens
yeah i don't want to be running around
being chased by guido the killer pimp
that's for sure i don't want to spend my
day over and over with joey pants
chasing me
and i don't want to [ __ ] with the memo
minder i'm looking for that for the
brothel knight if that's the case
because not only do we run a brothel and
there's lots of uh like
i'm a teenager and there's sex all
around me and [ __ ] something
as a teenager it's all we craved um but
also i meet my college entrance guy
get him laid and so i get to go to
[ __ ] a good school
like that would be that'd be a good
night to be trapped in india you get a
porsche to drive around
and then you ride the train with lana
you just got to make sure that that day
cuts off before
[ __ ] you know guido the killer pimp
shows up and [ __ ] steals all your
[ __ ] and then you got to buy it back
with all the money
i cannot believe how much i remember a
[ __ ] plot of risky business
it's troubling to me just like
busting loose i watched that an awful
lot oddly enough that movie didn't sink
deep into my creative dna and stuff but
but i did watch that movie a bunch
uh kids have you had a good time for
this past
19 hours of our [ __ ] non-stop podcast
if you did it's because of that dude the
dude
i can never do this right that dude that
dude
yes that dude look if i put my finger
here i'm i'm fingering mark's butt
yeah there you go
um give it up for uh for your new sound
for your
man with a plan uh and always full of
good ideas mr mark bernard
oh thank you sir god we thank you jc
for uh putting us out there uh for the
fine people to find
uh and and pray for uh the return
of uh the scum and villainy cantina
soon as soon as the [ __ ] world allows
us to open up anything you need to plug
gentlemen
uh plug free my friend if uh you wanna
you sure you're [ __ ] non sell a shirt
go to embattledclothing.com and use the
code mark
15 to say 15 off your first order if you
want to be humble
and let [ __ ] know all over your
chest
you gotta do it i'm gonna be on i'm
gonna be on my
twitch twitch.tv scum and villainy
cantina talking
star wars from seven to nine o'clock if
you wanna hear more nerd talk
if this two and a half hours wasn't
enough yeah if you're
like i just want to laser focus it on
star wars
um you'll be able to do that um all
right folks
thank you for hanging out we'll be doing
this again on saturday gentlemen
we will endeavor our best to not have
anything get in the way
next week one division episode five man
and [ __ ] batman sun in the dragon
again we're gonna be watching that of
the dragon the senator
there it is um so come on back
kids uh that is fat man beyond for this
week
tune in next week same that time
same well not the same bad times right
now earlier
that time saturday four o'clock same fat
channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith um the uh
[ __ ] i can't say for the good of all
cree because i realized that that's like
the cree were the bad guys
i need a new sign off um
can we pull anything from wanda vision
i don't i don't know if anybody's got
anything
overly oh i got one [ __ ] this is easy
ready
uh for family i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard tune in next time same fat time
saving fat child's podcast i got more
youtube guys i'm just giving smith
avengers assemble now that
because that that's something you do at
the beginning of the show
because if you if you if you assemble
the avengers and then you [ __ ] leave
they're all like wait we're
all in the room and you guys left now
you need like an autobots transforming
rollout
yeah or
and and i don't want to say by the power
of grace goal because that's the
beginning of something not the end
you seem to be stuck in a quandary
you can't end the show you need
something to [ __ ] say
paul boulder says sign off by going do
your taxes
14 hours later like i can't sign off i
don't know what to say i need a thing to
say
destro's arm says engage but that also
indicates the beginning of something
kneel before zod that tells a story that
you want to keep
hearing to infinity beyond
spoon spoon's not bad sally fourth
for the children why for the children oh
for moana vision no is that from one
division yeah i think so
um go home live long and prosper
alfred make me a sandwich
um avengers d assemble kong gone
i am iron man um
see this feels like what happens when
you workshop an ending
yeah it's unbelievable all right what
about wait what's a good line from jaws
[ __ ] uh hey what would be a good sign
off from jaws
they're well let me do the affair
spanish ladies
farewell and i do you ladies of spain
for we've received orders to sell back
to boston
and so nevermore will we see you again
this is lovely but it seems like an
awfully long sign off
um i guess i guess
i guess we don't need one stay classy
san diego that's funny
um all right
people are trying cobra retreat
um jonathan solieri saying from wanda
vision just say
no no
um please stand by that's not a bad one
please stand by but that indicates like
stick around and then we [ __ ] off for a
week
oh somebody suggested from clerks
akila jm says try not to suck any dick
on the way to the parking lot that is
the way to sign off ladies and gentlemen
i mean unless you want to be sucking
dick on the way in the parking lot but
sure let's try uh for family and beyond
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next time same that time same
pet channel spot guests.com or
you do the con class kevin smith try not
to suck any dick on your way through the
parking lot
that sounds that's that's
i don't know if that's the note to go
out on you know what if you were
watching the show with your parents and
then suddenly that happened
suddenly a dude in his bathroom
still like is that kind of kimono robe
and he's offering executives i'm sorry
goodnight and good luck yeah there's
yeah we could do that
you know what wakanda forever just
really works doesn't it
it's a good stand bye tune in next time
same fat time same fat channels
podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith wakanda
forever peace
you